[Music]
in best job ever news sounds wholesome
again and you you went okay oh is this
the one where you get to squeeze the
bees so hard that their stingers pop off
it's the Beast we've never heard about
that no those are for the honeybees the
sting poppers that'll be die that's like
a game we can play
they steam you they die but if you
squeeze them and they pop off you don't
know without the entrails coming out
yeah submitted by the fake Slim Shady
not the real Slim Shady please sit down
please sit down please sit down a
Swedish experimental project plans to
hire someone to do nothing for the rest
of their life oh my god I would kill
myself that's i was thinkin look kill
themselves I want to know what the
result is but I actually don't want to
do it are they so they keep getting paid
right what is nothing what are we
talking about I want to know what
nothing because most people think they
want to be lazy and do nothing but then
when they're actually in that job it's
actually the most depressing job what is
the criteria what is nothing what's
going on here so this is a
government-funded conceptual art project
government job almost close to doing
nothing
yeah you said it all my friends the same
[ __ ] all the colors government job
pretending to work Gothenburg Sweden
I wanna go Sweden so they will select
one lucky applicant and 2025 and so this
whole thing is because they had this
competition I'm trying to figure out
like who can have the best design ideas
for cotton Berg's train station course
vagan train station course bhagam course
Saban bargain they were offering a prize
of 7 million Swedish Krona which is
about 750 thousand dollars to the
winners what their [ __ ] currencies
called best joke
Crona yeah give me your kroner dough and
you have to get out
pouch-like house in sweden i feel like
they would be like like digital and like
holographic and like see-through and
[ __ ] that's a way better than what i
just said i was thinking a coin purse
yeah that's what I was thinking for sure
how much Crona for your goat weird um I
thought it was gonna be like she didn't
watch Game of Thrones no I like a lot of
medieval [ __ ] though Game of Thrones I
used to love hercules and xena warrior
you're the same [ __ ] Game of Thrones
oh really with Kevin Sorbo no I used to
watch slap fight you know why I like
Xena I like yeah it's not the same cuz I
love Greek mythology oh you would love
it they're not Greek but that's a ton of
backstory in it
backstory mythology yeah you would the
Seas and all that dude did you see that
big okay am I going oh this all boy dad
okay go yes so they ended up winning or
picking the winners as this Swedish
artist duo where they suggested that the
prize money would be used to pay one
worker salary for the rest of their
lives so for eternity and so they called
this project in eternal employment and
that's for about a hundred and twenty
years or more what 700,000 they could do
that oh well they figured it all out and
so they're saying that they will be able
there's a 75% chance that they'll be
able to pay a two thousand three hundred
and twelve dollar monthly wage plus an
annual salary increase of 3.2 percent
four hundred twenty years and so this
employee all they're required to do is
go into the train station clock in then
this light will appear and that
indicates to everyone at the train
station that this worker is now like
clocked in like working and then this
worker does not have to stay there they
can leave they just have to make sure to
come back clock out and and then the
light will turn off well that's hard and
so they just have to go to train station
two times a day they are not allowed to
get in to have any other paying job as
long as they can I say if I do this can
I have an assistant you do whatever you
want your money others it's a retina
scan
have the assistant just clock in and
clock out and you go to another country
and I'm out but then you only have
$2,000 a month though I mean but I've
got to do [ __ ] yeah they get a starving
artist celery yeah you could do whatever
you want yeah like my job secure for the
rest of my life contract I wasn't known
if the contract is just like you have to
physically do it and they don't let you
game it yeah you have to physically
because that's what's hard like you
don't get any vacation day that's
working itself you have to be there
every day and yet the clock in and clock
out at the same time you can't get
another job you can't get another job
this sounds like a government experiment
to test my patience cuz I don't want to
go in and if you test my patience yeah
big like that what happens if you're
later what happens if you get lazy you
don't want to go I would be late on this
every day I mean like would you lose
your contract like what goes mean they
do states that you may be replaced my
mom would love this [ __ ] cuz mom never
takes a sick day my mom like state like
she likes routine she doesn't like big
changes she doesn't give a [ __ ] about
holidays like she's about this my mom
would love this too she would just go in
yeah tap she'll go home make some kimchi
come back that's my mom [ __ ] but don't
they like it because they're actually
working I think my mom can work doing
other things though like she doesn't
have to work oh you mean like housework
probably just stay there and start
organizing the [ __ ] at the train station
yeah but the laws you can't work for
that person right or maybe get another
job so it's like you can't actually work
at the train station
you could clock in and just sit there no
you can you can do whatever you want so
you could o'clock believe and that's oh
no cuz I I thought see a better
experiment would be you can't do [ __ ]
yes it that yeah crazy yeah that's what
I'm saying it's like you don't have to
do anything you just have to sit there
no Mike you like you could watch Netflix
all day yeah yeah you know go to a park
I'll go fishing skee-ball you have to
come back yeah the hard thing is
clocking in and clocking out because if
you want to go on a fishing trip you can
can yeah and I'm so entitled I would
like I would start to find arguments for
this I'd be like this isn't fair
good like because for me that defeats
the purpose of actual freedom because
you're still bound to something so
that's probably the difficult part right
so if you're still living this life for
you who have this clock in and clock out
you're bound to something for the rest
of your life so if you want to go travel
somewhere cut that out of your life
rather work 12 hours and do it then to
do this
he gets weekends off I don't know I
don't know about weekend did you find
someone no so they're gonna find this
person in 2025 that's a long time not
really dude five years I'm living in
2020 it sounds like such a such a simple
job to announce now it's not like it's
not like hey we're gonna we need at am a
time-traveling conductor for our
time-traveling machine it's gonna have
happen in 2013 you're like oh I can see
as part of this competition and the fact
that they accepted to do this and it's
government-funded there's so many people
are like are you [ __ ] kidding me our
taxpayer money are going to this what do
they really try to [ __ ] Sweden they're
saying that so a lot of people are
calling this stupid and worthless and a
waste of money and they're like but yeah
that's the whole idea of government and
since I aren't that much or the artists
are saying that I don't know we do this
like that though right because I have a
couple friends from Sweden they have a
lot of government funding for arts not
to me that's pretty cool Sweden for like
this terrible Swedish like film director
or some [ __ ]
and he just they just gave him millions
and millions of dollars to create theif
you Bowl the the worst [ __ ] film's
ever on earth and then when he finally
got his funding cut he was so pissed off
and he did like this whole he was
entitled yeah and so they had that may
even like its but they their government
takes a [ __ ] ton out of your income so
when you live like out for two thousand
something dollars a month it's actually
very very [ __ ] livable so you have I
think like in I think what he told me
was like if you go to like college over
they give you a laptop and everything
it's damn near impossible to be homeless
so if you lose your job in Sweden you
can go to a government agency and
they'll assign you a job the next day so
if you are homeless in Sweden this is
what was told to me from Superman this
is like the country of consolation
prizes yeah that if you do live in
Sweden he goes is virtually impossible
for you not to have a job Sweden is
already like clocking in and clocking
out and not doing [ __ ]
compared to u.s. job is it's like your
governments actually doing their job and
taking care of you rather [ __ ] have
my own I'd rather have my own mistakes
and not have the government be my parent
I rather [ __ ] make my own mistakes
make my own [ __ ] money have my own
dreams I'm [ __ ] free USA [ __ ] that
mother Bush here so if we all move to
Sweden you're gonna say [ __ ] that I'm
staying here in the you know go cuz I
heard that they got really good candy I
like swedish fish that's one of my
favorite ones whooping is it come from
there oh wait that's me Marlon no
swedish swedish fish no i'm singing
about chocolate switzerland swiss was
shocked to learn lost yeah I've never
seen it automatic of us all that need
cuz mining Switzerland I'm like
chocolate you know yeah I feel like I've
never seen that on a man I think you
leave a Christmas I think Belgium is
Belgium chocolate and chocolate Swiss
chocolate hey [ __ ] tell me you
[ __ ] Mexicans about Mexican hot
chocolate Oh Mexican hot chocolate that
[ __ ] never talked about sweet [ __ ]
though you always talk about savory and
my dishes that's true but I never how
[ __ ] delicious
I've had success miss my [ __ ] that [ __ ]
dude
and let's get hot chocolate [ __ ] but
always good too
oh yeah it comes with just like a brick
of chocolate Mexican hot drinks we're
not very Mexican at my house oh and in
Mexican we're very Korean at our house
Mexican coffee
it's made with cinnamon yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]